our partners now ship about a billion
CPUs a month or rather that's a billion
chips containing CPUs the graphics
processors are still you know we're
catching up we will do about 700 million
units this year can you tell me about
that where's the factory where do you
make the chips here what are the
factories in Taiwan in Austin Texas and
China and you know all those sorts of
places so what happens is we design so
25 years ago
literally the founders of armed people
like Mike mother we're taking a sheet of
acetate and putting down tape strips on
it which is where the origin of the
phrase tape out comes from and they made
images of a chip which were then photo
reduced and you produce chips what we do
now is we write hardware just like most
people write software in a special
language and then that language is
compiled down to gates and gates or
gates NAND gates all of that sort of
thing and via the magic of some software
produced by some very clever tools
companies that's all then spat out and
it produces those pictures
they're called masks and they cost about
a million dollars two million dollars
each time you press print on one of
those and then those are used as the
basis of a is really a photography
process it's called photo lithography
but it's really printing and they print
these incredibly credibly small features
which are the chips you mentioned some
big numbers they're like who has to make
that cool if it's costing millions to
print these things who makes that call
says yeah let's go for it so it's broken
down so a modern complex chip will
contain an enormous number of components
and they don't all come from art by any
means so we will supply what we call IP
intellectual property so we will design
sections of that chip and those are our
products that's what we sell which go to
our part
our partners are then the guys who are
really designing those chips and they'll
say I'll have this CPU I'll have this
GPU I'll connect it with this I'm going
to put my magic down in the corner here
and some stuff around the outside and
then they put it all together and they
are the ones who eventually say go Press
print but of course there are lots of
gates along the way there to us giving
it to them and us saying we think it's
okay or we think it's okay for limited
production yeah we think it's fine you
know go go for it big time so there are
a number of quality barriers along the
way which which have to be reached and
one of the big thing about selling IP is
not that you're designing something
you're designing something that works
and your partners can trust so before it
ever goes near silicon we have simulated
it millions and billions of times and
hopefully then it means that when you
actually come to build it it all works
I know there are some people out there
who use things like Minecraft to do
simulations or make logic gates and all
this sort of stuff is this a bit like
that but on a massive scale you're
actually using the chips to to practice
using new potential chip now let me get
that right that's right we are using
chips we're using computers running
programs to simulate the function of
silicon gates and the way in which we
put those gates together in a timing
accurate simulator fashion and then
there's all various other things we do
as well which is as well as simulate it
logically we simulate it electrically
which because we then feed in a model of
what the chip is the silicon process is
going to look like to our partners in
the foundries those guys who actually
make chips they tell us how that silicon
works you feed that into another model
you simulated electrically and yeah it
all comes good and that's that helps you
know things like how how hot it will run
and things like that I'm guessing yes
so we're simulating how hot it goes is
actually still very hard but we do do it
obviously simulate how fast it will go
is easier and simulate whether it will
be correct if the answer is 1 or 0 is
this is essential and we work on the
basis of that and the chips are now so
complex so big and so massive that it's
a progressive decomposition so we will
simulate a very small blocks when you
get that correct you put those box
together you make a bigger block when
you say that's correct you put those
together you know and finally you get
GPU and then you put that together with
the CPU and some memory and some
interconnect and you simulate that and
then you give that to the partner and he
puts more stuff on and he simulates that
and eventually if he's feeling bold he
says some yeah get my checkbook out for
our audience who don't know what a
checkbook is that's something that old
people used to spend money with so we
make some IP blogs there'll be other
companies making some IP blocks then you
sell it to a company that he's making
chips and they'll have some of their own
IP they put that all together they make
those chips and then they sell that to
an OEM who makes a real consumer device
like like a phone so in Samsung's case
they might make their own chips and sell
them to their a division that makes
phones and then that division that makes
phones might also buy chips from
somebody else they might borrow chips
from Qualcomm say and then some of these
companies don't actually physically make
the chips themselves when they finally
got the design sorted they then give it
to a company called a foundry like tsmc
Taiwanese semiconductor company and they
make a huge proportion of the world's
chips themselves when it works this
chain has got experts doing what they're
really good at putting it together and
making great products it foundry brings
to mind people a very hot room with the
cameras and other stuff which I love the
idea of but would you say you're a bit
like architects and you or selling plan
yes absolutely so a lot of our dessert
so when our designers get really really
good they get the job title of architect
and yes sometimes when you go to other
countries your business card gets
translated into man who builds houses
but our architect in our industry means
something
quite senior you know a person who is
responsible for the design of a block he
might have some people working for him
who are actually building parts of that
block that he's responsible for that
overall design and ultimately yes I
think your analogy is very good it comes
to a set of plans what we deliver to
people is not it's not bricks and mortar
we deliver those plans to somebody who
then builds that house they might buy
bricks from a number of different people
so there are there are only really a
handful of foundries in the world who
were making the molten silicon processes
so they will choose to have them built
at one of those
although arm says we never make chips
actually we do make a very small number
of test chips but a big a big volume
production run for us would be five
hundred chips yeah that would be huge
for us and that's does like taking the
testing to next level prototype it yes
so we do I mean the thing about testing
is if you do it all of one kind then
you're building in a whole bunch of
assumptions that you might not even know
you're doing so if you go down one
direction I'll simulate this this this
this and this and it works you got
highest fine and what you really want
the best confidence is right I'm going
to do this but actually I'm going to do
it from over here and I'll simulate it a
completely different way and I'll come
at it with a whole bunch of different
assumptions and if that still works you
know we might be onto something here
so we simulate we we originally will
model the design in our in a high-level
language a software model then we write
the hardware and simulate the hardware
and we will do that in those racks and
racks and racks of CPUs we will also put
it into specialist hardware emulation
machines we will put it into FPGAs field
programmable devices and and we will
also connect existing chips with a
particular IP block so you know what
this is like in real silicon you're just
adding in this little
it over here we do that and you know the
more forms of testing and testing with
different sets of assumptions that more
likely it is it's all going to work
or here's the table here's the floor
where which bits of the floor and which
bits of this table can I see so you have
to do a lot of matrix solving to